hey guys welcome back to my kitchen
today we're going to make churros and
I'm not sure how to really do this
because I don't think that I have all
the necessary things that I need to make
the churros but I think we're gonna
figure it out so the step one is get all
of my ingredients so I need vegetable
oil of which I have I'm not sure why I'm
yelling but I am this quick mix I'm
going to do the shake and pour because
it says just add water and I don't know
I don't know ground cinnamon I've got
that sugar heat oil two to three inches
over medium-high heat until thermometer
inserted oil what does that mean I also
have a proper pan for this this is not a
court what is a quart 3 quart saucepan I
will just put that there
all up put some oil in it a lot of oil
in the pan this is not going to work
I don't think this is gonna work my
confidence is very low for this cooking
endeavor ok except a nice little camera
so we'll be able to get the churro shot
and it says I need to mix some cinnamon
and some sugar together so that's we're
gonna do so dump some of this in here
I'm not sure how much cinnamon I think
it's a 2 tablespoons we don't measure
here remember don't forget this magical
mix add 1 and 1/2 cups cool water to
container
alright 1/2 shake container hard this
says I don't know
shake Maddy lose the music make you feel
so good I have bought a thermometer for
this project
hey Paul this is RuPaul pop up up a
poultry buppa buppa buppa done how does
this work do I stick it in something
just I don't think this is the type of a
mama that I need yeah be careful because
that's how those house fires burn really
yeah okay listen I might need you to
stand by if there is an oil fire what do
you do
google it I don't know I usually just
therefore the aftermath google it
let's mix up our cinnamon sugar mixture
it says it's got to be 375 degrees we're
not quite there yet so Jen inform me
that there is ever a grease fire you put
something metal over top of the pot to
Needham turn the heat down do not lift
up the pan on the fire baking soda on
the fire extinguisher works fire
extinguisher works as well on the fire
call 911
leave the house and call 9-1-1 haha very
boring but this can all be prevented if
you do you just watch while you're
cooking
okay I'm not like this is gonna get to
375 degrees so I think I'm just gonna
try to dump it in and see what happens
that's not how chemistry works yeah but
I'm afraid this is um I don't want to
wait should I not do this that is not a
churro
this is going to be a freaking pancake
wait what I do is I can maybe I can fold
it and mold it into a churro
this will look like this is like a
churro go Oh God
you know what maybe let's do this wait
hold man come here baby I lift up this
all in here can you mess with a big cake
in the crop shakes like sure truthfully
I don't think this is a good idea this
is a bad idea this is a bad idea
this is a really bad idea I'm basically
making like I'm not sure what I'm doing
what's happening right now okay
I think I'm making funnel cake and I'm
making a funnel cake this can't be good
for you is this a churro or not that's
what I'd like to know Oh God
don't go off pan so when I said I was
making churros for the party this looks
disgusting this is not a churro this is
a mistake wonder what our temperature is
not 375 degrees it's 186 I'm gonna let
that just stop out of there put you here
and we're going to turn this into a
really successful funnel cake and I'm
going to bring it to the party
we wait
all right I'm about given up hope I
think let's spoon let's just work it
we're gonna stop this cuz clearly
nothing is good nothing well as good
from this I'm going to scoop it out and
put it on our plate might as well make a
nice presentation this looks just like a
date on Pinterest this looks like mashed
potatoes you guys are all liars those
full of lies there is so much oil on
this that I'm gonna throw up
this is mashed potatoes hey Jenna
please just take a taste
it looks like hashbrowns here we go
puts lots of sugar on it the cinnamon
and sugar will balance out everything
this is what I'd like to call hash brown
churros you've got to taste it
buy yourself a fork it's deep fried
pancake okay go ahead taste it it might
be hot Cheers okay now you gotta go
first
oh I mean it kids freaking awesome yeah
he's a go oh my god
oh it's sugar and fat and oh oh oh yeah
this guy's great it's exactly so friggin
good
it tastes like pancakes that aren't
cooked enough that has a whole duncanon
of sugar on it
somebody call 9-1-1 cuz i'm bothered
seriously kill over should we just go to
the hospital now I'm gonna take this and
show up at the ER and be like oh okay
well it tastes good but I can't bring
this to the party because I'm
embarrassed and it actually looks so
disgusting but hey I mean even
embarrassed that I'm posting this video
on photos coffin so what we got I gotta
go I'll show you guys later
do not try this at home because if you
do I'm not liable for anything that you
do bye